grasset ce totem et d'étranges panneaux
une listériose forêt va dévoiler ses
secrets
alors regardez les indices soudain
l'émerveillement se lit sur les visages
des cabanes tout là haut dans les arbres
c'est là que deux familles ont choisi de
se mettre au vert suspendu à ce chêne
bicentenaire un intérieur très con de
quoi retomber dans l'enfant c'est un
rêve de gamin la cabane c'est tout soit
bouclé des cabanes quand on était petit
et c'est 100 % écolo on trie ses déchets
on a eu paul est sèche
donc c'est une petite aventure là pour
faciliter la montée vous allez des
encoches les indiana jones qui sommeille
en chacun de nous peut vite se réveiller
à condition de ne pas avoir le vertige
les cabanes sont perchés entre 5 et 8
mètres de hauteur
elles sont bien accrochés 7 itqane même
si tu as une tempête elles ont résisté
non mais elles sont bien d'approché avec
des haubans et système de serrage au
niveau de la cabane au niveau du tronc
et elles sont bien installés les fêtes
ceci sans eau courante ni électricité on
retrouve l'ambiance des veillées
d'autrefois
la télé ne manquent pas aux enfants la
forêt ravive leur imaginaire donc devant
rapporter des choses de la forêt patron
pendant neuf heures le lendemain le
petit déjeuner est servi pas vraiment
comme un hôtel la nuit laissera de bons
souvenirs
le cracker un des arbres et le silence
en état le sillage dernières photos
familiales derniers instants de quiétude
avant de redescendre sur terre